justin mike congratulations your hard
work has paid off in the first two
rounds of competition so that means the
two of you are moved forward in the
third and final round we're sending you
back to build an iconic weapon from
history
and that weapon is this
the continental cavalry sabre
the continental cavalry saber was an
iconic sword used during the american
revolutionary war while this style of
sword was originally built for british
soldiers american blade smith started
reproducing them for the continental
soldiers these long-curved single-edged
blades delivered lethal cuts against
british soldiers as the continental army
ambushed them from horseback these
american swords were famously wheeled by
revolutionaries during the battle of
princeton in 1777 where george
washington defeated the british retaking
new jersey and forcing the british
retreat into new york
all right guys well one of you is going
to be coming back here with the blade
worth ten thousand dollars so we want to
see your very best work so good luck
we'll see you in four days
my name is justin hammond i'm 28 years
old i'm a full-time bladesmith and i am
from lockhart texas
before bladesmithing i was a chef for
about 12 years if i win i just found out
that my wife lost her wedding band so
i'm going to buy my wife in the wedding
band
biggest challenge is getting the
curvature just right this is a long
i've got my blade parameters met it's
time to quench
taking my time
anything can go wrong when you heat
treat
and she worked that's what i wanted to
see i wanted to start getting some
measurements taken
i'm about an eighth of an inch shy on my
curve
the only way for me to get the length i
need is to stick her back in the fire
goodbye heat treat
i need to try and get this curve to
parameters puts a lot of stress on a
sword couldn't pick up a crack but i
don't have time to make another one
this quench has to be perfect
as long as there's no cracks i should be
okay
oh yeah
quenches went well very relieved to see
that who gets to be so lucky so i have
two successful crunches
i'm good to go like finish the blade
yesterday so there's nothing left to do
but fit and finish
i love it when i finish up a blade on
wednesday because i get to do all my
hand sanding once watching one of my
favorite tv shows the sword is assembled
it's complete it's sharp so let's go
ahead and test it
it just kind of barely glinted into my
hand a little bit the guard hitting the
judge's knuckle was certainly something
that could send me home man i've got to
fix this
i'd be able to just bend this out a
little bit and just weld it a little bit
higher up
it's comfortable i can't wait to see it
tested though
i absolutely love this thing
my name is michael ovalle i'm from fort
polk louisiana i'm 34 years old and i'm
currently serving the united states
military
what got me into bladesmithing is my
friend tyler hackbarth ford fire
champion previously on the show we
deployed together back in 2007 and good
friends ever since and i'm just proud to
represent it's a healthy stack
this is like the most stressful part
just getting the initial wells instead
after smashing repeatedly these welds
are set
it's time to start cranking up the heat
and let's get this thing dried out i
have to get my heat treat in make sure i
get it evenly as heated as possible
there's always a warp as a possibility
and they happen i've spent two days
making this sword here we go
i need this quench to go right
all right that'll work
so the quench went good so now i just
gotta get my handle together and make a
guard there we go
in around three i'm feeling good i was a
little worried i wouldn't have enough
time to finish but i was able to do it
and blade's a little heavier than i
wanted but i'm happy with how it turned
out and
will it kill i think it would
late smiths welcome to the dynamic kill
test
to find out just how durable your
weapons are i'm going to cut through
this pink carcass and these drums
just need your first you ready for this
let's do it
so
all right justin song about your saber
here
first up your handle construction
it is nice and smooth it's avoid enough
to where i have a very good grip now for
a saber design i usually see the curves
a little bit up front over here but it
wasn't an issue overall sir your saber
it will kill
all right mike your turns are you ready
you're ready let's do this
all right mike your blade is beautiful i
really like the damascus package that
you put on it
it's a little bit on the heavier side so
when i'm striking with this on the
recovery it wants to shift a little bit
on the handle construction here but in
the beating and cutting of the drum your
edge stayed true overall sir your saber
you'll keel thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for our
dynamic strength test
to test the overall construction of your
blade as well as how it feels in my hand
i'll be attacking our british warship
here
justin you're up are you ready ready
when you are okay
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
suggesting first off everything's in one
piece blade's still just as sharp as it
was but having that curve here
as opposed out here the weight is kind
of behind where i'm expecting it to be
but it did a great job it held up
beautifully nicely done thank you sir
ready to go mike i'm ready okay
[Music]
so
all right mike right off a really nice
job the pattern on this is really pretty
but this is a heavy weapon with all that
weight it's very difficult to stop that
blade but it held up it's in one piece
nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths well both of your
blades performed extremely well but the
time has come for our judges to decide
which one of you is leaving here with
the title of fortune fire champion and a
check for ten thousand dollars today's
fortune fire champion is
justin congratulations
mike you did an extremely good job but
unfortunately your blade did not make
the cut and doug's gonna tell you why
mike it wasn't an easy decision because
that's a fine blade that performed quite
well but at the end of the day the sheer
weight of your blade made it hard for us
to control for that reason we're saying
you know
well mike
myself and the judges would all like to
say thank you so much for coming to the
forge showing us your craft but
unfortunately your time in this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the fourth
floor okay that's right thank you so
much
good job mike good job
i feel like the judges made a good call
my weapon was a little heavier than i
would have liked it actually be able to
make the continental calvary saber was
like an honor and consent of the
military so it's a good experience
justin buddy congratulations you are the
fortune fire champion you just got
yourself a check for ten thousand
dollars well done
how you feeling
damn
i just unfortunate fire
yeah what are people who are gonna say
i can't wait to get out of here and give
him a phone call because i can't wait to
tell him
damn
you